(acoustic music)
- [Voiceover] Before
I've tried basketball.
I tried football.
Really, I just felt better
with an ax in my hand.
At Southern Illinois I had the opportunity
to become a lumberjack.
- [Voiceover] Contestants ready!
Three, two, one!
(whistle blows)
(saw saws)
(ax chops)
- My name's Jack Cearley.
I'm the president of the
Southern Illinois
University Forestry Club.
- [Voiceover] Here you
go ladies, you got this!
- [Voiceover] Come on girls, let's go!
- We're at the 64th
Midwest Forestry Conclave
in Oswald, Missouri put
on by Mizzou University.
This year I believe
there's 11 or 12 schools
competing throughout the
midwest here at the Conclave.
(whistle blows)
(saw saws)
Some of the events going on here
are the underhand chop, single buck,
single sawing, double sawing,
jack jack saw, jack jill saw, bolt toss.
We also do events like tree ID and wood ID
and traverse, where we
have to use coordinates
and forestry measurements to
find our way through the woods.
You know, I'm lucky if I'm
still standing when I'm done.
(crowd shouts in encouragement)
All the events that we
do, they all come from
traditional forestry skills.
So this is our way of keeping
all those skills alive.
Forestry, I always like to think about
the old Greek proverb,
"Society grows great
"when men plant trees whose
shade they'll never sit in."
And that really speaks to
me when it comes to forestry
because in forestry, we're
working very long term scales.
I'm gonna maybe put forth management plans
that can effect my kids or my grandkids,
and so if I put in a
trail I wanna make sure
that trail is done right,
if we're gonna cut timber
I wanna make trees get planted afterwards.
You know it's a very long term process.
When you're out there,
announcer says your name
over the speakers, and the
whole team just cheers,
your family's screamin' and
you can't do anything but smile
and you just want to grab the ax and you
wanna chop the wood as fast as you can.
This is just where I belong.
(ax chops)
(birds chirp)